WIL WILLIS: Blade
smiths, congratulations.
You made it through a really
brutal round of testing.
And now here you are,
that much closer to being
"Forged in Fire" champions.
Well, now we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic weapon.
Ready to see what it is?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
[ninja sounds]
Yah!
The nine ring broadsword.
Good luck, blade smiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Thank you.
Good luck.
BURTON: It's day one
here at the home forge.
I don't really have much
experience making something
this big or this wide.
The plan for today is I've got
to get to the end of the sword
drawn out quite a ways.
I'm going to use 1080 steel.
Nice big heavy bar of it.
1080 is nice, hard steel
that's forgiving for heat
treatment in an open forge.
Let her start warming up.
I'm doing most of the
work on the press.
My plan is, just
to kind of get it
worked out a little bit here.
Just trying to break that
down and spread it out.
Heat her back up.
It has to be a minimum
of two and a half
to four inches from the tip.
So I'm going to go for
three, that way I've
got a little bit of
movement to do any tweaks
I need to after heat-treat.
I'm halfway there, maybe.
Yeah, tip's coming
right in there now.
It's starting to take
shape of a sword.
That's it for day one.
We are at my home forge.
I start forging the blade today.
And I'm looking to have it
fully forged hopefully midday
tomorrow to where I can
start doing some grinding.
My biggest concern with
this blade is heat-treat.
I'd really, really hate
to have to start over
again at the end of day two.
I've got a lot of
meat in this thing
that needs to be thinned out.
Fortunately, I have a power
hammer that's going to help
a lot with making that happen.
Oh, you've got to be
[bleep] kidding me.
All of a sudden, my
power hammer decides it
doesn't want to play anymore.
It stops working.
That sucks.
So in-between heats
now, I'm trying
to rewire my power hammer.
All right, well,
that ain't working.
Finally get the
switch back together.
Ta-da.
It's alive.
So I'm working on the
blade and drawing it out.
And I notice there's
a crack in the blade.
[sigh] And there's
no saving this.
Yeah, it's junk.
So my back-up steel is 01.
It is a tool steel.
But it's not a good
steel for swords.
Hopefully I can temper it
right and it'll still hold
together through the testing.
BURTON: It's day
two for me today.
I'm going to go ahead and
take some of the 3/16 rod.
And we'll scroll and jig
and try to set up some,
like, inch and a half rings.
I'm going to hot cut
them off one at a time.
Once they get
attached on the sword,
then I'll just give
them a little TIG weld
to hold them together on there.
We're getting ready try to
drill the holes for the rings.
It could have possibly got
too hard in the forging.
Find out here in a second.
Looks like it's
drilling like butter.
First two holes drill just fine.
[grinding noise]
That's harder.
[bleep] Oh, I was hoping
they would drill easy.
[grinding noise]
That's what I was afraid of.
It can't be a nine
ring sword without nine
holes for the rings to go in.
Feeling the clock now.
It's not soft.
I'm going to heat the spine
of it up with the torch
and try to just draw it
back and hopefully it'll
be soft enough that I
can get those last seven
holes punched through it.
If this doesn't
work, I'm screwed.
I'd hate to start forging again.
MIKE: There's still a heck
of a lot of work to do.
So it's critical that I really
hit the heat-treat tonight.
If it breaks, if
it cracks, if it
does anything other than
quenches hard and straight,
I'm done.
I have no backups anymore.
We've got a hard blade.
It's straight.
So as I started
profiling the blade more,
all of a sudden I notice
something's gone wrong again.
I've got a [bleep]
crack in the blade.
I have no more
steel to work with.
All right, so how do I fix that?
I decide to just put scallops
in between all of the eyelets
for the rings, and hopefully
grind far enough down where
I'm beyond where the crack is.
No more crack.
Doesn't look like the picture.
But i kind of like it,
to tell you the truth.
I got some sweet tea.
Day four, finally punched
through the last hole.
So now we've got a
nine hole broadsword.
Got the sword
quenched yesterday.
But I'm still under the gun.
Time to get all these
rings welded on here.
Does rattle-- they're on there.
I'm going to use a camo color
para cord to do the wrap.
And it gives enough grip
and thickness to the handle.
[laughs] Thing's beastly.
I'm finished.
It's sharp.
It's an instrument of death.
It's a wild thing.
Thing looks wicked.
MIKE: First thing I'm
getting after is the rings.
I'm going with eighth-inch
[inaudible] steel.
I created a jig a while back
for bending this kind of stuff.
I'm going to put
it in the jig, bend
them around until they're pretty
symmetrical and pretty even.
Yeah, not too bad.
So all I have left to do is get
these rings welded in place.
Boy, that looks like
[bleep] it just doesn't want
to weld together very well.
I mean, it starts to melt.
It starts to do other things.
Damn it.
But finally, blade's finished.
Nine ring broadsword, brother.
I love this thing.
I'd like to keep it,
put it on my wall.
But I'd rather have 10 grand.
Blade smiths, you
have our gratitude.
Gentlemen, your swords
look magnificent.
But are they deadly?
To find that out, we
will take your swords
and deliver some clean
blows on this pig carcass.
It's all about the kill
in this particular test.
Burton, you are first.
Are you ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
Pretty much what could go
wrong is the blade breaks
or it's not sharp enough to
cut what it's supposed to cut.
Let's see how it holds up.
[dramatic music]
Damn.
[gasps]
Well, there it went.
Goodness, look at that.
All right, Burton.
First up, what I love about
this blade was the balance,
the way I was able to move
with the blade everywhere.
Now let's talk
about the breakage.
OK, so the break
happened right there,
where the ring was attached.
You can see it's
really not a bad core
structure you have there.
It could be finer.
But rings, when you're
digging into that
could cost stress risers--
and it broke right
there with the ring was.
Well, gentlemen, the
fight is not over.
Because Mike, your blade still
has to survive nine strikes
on its kill test target.
Good luck, gentlemen.
Doug?
MIKE: Burton's blade broke
right at one of the holes.
I have them same holes in there.
Plus on my spine, I've
already had two cracks.
I'm terrified it's
going to break.
Oh, the heart's starting
to flutter a little bit.
[dramatic music]
Good job, bro.
Burton, unfortunately your
blade broke and it can no
longer continue with testing.
And for that reason, I have
to dismiss you from the forge.
Good job, brother.
- I appreciate it, man.
That sucks.
[inaudible]
Gorgeous weapon, though.
Seeing my blade break,
it's a disappointment.
You know, you make it to
round three, you want to win.
You know, them nine holes
burnt through four drill bits
doing them.
So somewhere through
there, I probably
was giving a little
too much pressure
and caused the stress riser
to run down that blade.
That was enough to cause a
critical failure in that blade.
I'm still proud of myself
with what I've done.
You know, it was way
out of my wheelhouse.
What's next for
me is not swords,
especially nine ring swords,
[laughs] that's for damn sure.
WIL WILLIS: Mike,
congratulations.
The strength and
integrity of your blade
has made you a "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
[clapping]
I won 'Forged in Fire."
Holy crap, man.
Come on forward and
shake our hands, my friend.
Thank you.
- Good job, brother.
- Thank you.
With some of the things that
went wrong in my home forge,
I was really sure that that
blade was going to break on me.
But it didn't.
(SINGING) Da da da.
This is a happy dance.
Doing a little dance.
[music playing]